IS THAT STAR PLAYER.
THE TOP OF THE BARRIE'S GLOVE.
FINDS McDAVID.
M
AVALANCHE ZONE.
>> Peter: DARCY KUEMPER IS AT
THE TOP OF HIS GAME. J THE
SMALLEST OPP
INTO THE BACK OF THE MIKKO RANTN
WRIST SHOT.
A BIG SAVE BY SMITH.CIRCLE.
PICKED UP BY NICHUSHKIN.
>> Peter: THEY WERE DOING THE
TOP UNIT FOR THEHISTLE.
McDAVID.
FRONT SHOT.
SCORE.
DRAISAITL.
LET'S HAVE ANOTHER
I BELIEVE IT MIGHT HAVE GONE OFF
KADRI.
THERE WERE BOUNCES OFF OF NURSEN
FRONT.
IT C C
YAMAMOTO DOWN DEEP.
SHOT. WHO HAS BEEN A GOALTHREE-.
MIKKO.
STEERS IT OFF.MACKINNON.
DOWN LOW.
IT IS OFF THE POST FROM
RADOW
SHOWING OFF HIS SPEED.
HYMAN.HE UPPER BODY.
MACDERMID AND KANE
BACK TO KADRI PUSHED TO MAKAR. O
IT HAS BEEN A GREAT GAME TO
WATCH.T IS NOT NURSE COVERING H
THAT GUY IS IN TROUBL POKED AWA.
McDAVID COULDN'T COME UP WITH A
SCORE